on l'apprend seulement aujourd'hui mais
depuis le début de la semaine 14
personnes dont 13 enfants sont
hospitalisés gravement intoxiquées dans
plusieurs départements du sud ouest
elles ont en commun d'avoir consommé des
steaks hachés surgelés acheter dans les
magasins leclerc neuf de ces enfants
sont dans un état préoccupant
les lots à risque ont été retirées de la
vente le point avec christelle meyrals
ses parents viennent de vivre dix jours
éprouvants leur enfant de neuf ans et
demi et hospitalisé ici à toulouse
depuis la semaine dernière à la suite
d'une grave intoxication alimentaire
sans doute lié à la consommation de
steaks a varié l'enfant a subi trois
dialyses et deux transfusions dans le
week end les parents sont désormais
soulagés elle est nouvelle pour notre
fils sont plutôt rassurantes maintenant
mais bon quand on est arrivé
on savait pas
on savait pas qu'elle allait être
l'évolution
commence à l'espace et enfin s'il allait
s'en tirer sans séquelles ou pas on a
vraiment vécu ça au jour le jour et dans
l'angoissé évidemment dans le sud ouest
huit autres enfants de 2 à 9 ans sont
hospitalisés
leur pronostic vital n'est pas engagé il
aurait aussi consommer de la viande
toxiques tous sont victimes d'un mal
rare le syndrome hémolytique et urémique
une forme grave de complications de
gastro entérite due à une bactérie
l'escherichia coli elle se développe
surtout chez les enfants et les
personnes âgées
les principaux symptômes sont la fièvre
les douleurs au niveau du ventre mais
des douleurs qui sont douloureuses
longue ex mal calmé par les traitements
habituels des diarrhées aussi avec du
son mais qui persistent dans le temps
c'est pas quelque chose qui va durer 24
48 heures ça persiste dans le temps
malgré les 39 le traitement habituel
donné par exemple au cours d'une
consultation par l'homme par le médecin
et sa durée l'enfance épuisés se
fatiguent au total 14 personnes auraient
été intoxiqués par des steaks hachés
surgelés de marque chantegril il aurait
été mis en vente dans des magasins
leclerc dans quinze départements du sud
ouest leclerc procède au rappel des lots
à variés portant les numéros l 231 et l
234 date limite 22 août 2006 le lot l2
sont six portes lui la date limite du 25
juillet 2006 tous ces lots ont été
préparés par la société soviba des
analyses sont en cours pour déterminer
les causes de l'intoxication